beginnt die pressekonferenz ein
tragischer von sehr trauriger tag
für die german wings und für die gesamte
lufthansa familie
ich muss ihnen leider mitteilen dass wir
heute über den französischen department
als die rot orange südfrankreich ein
flugzeug der germanwings verunglücktes
dieses flugzeug war auf dem weg zu einem
planmäßigen linienflug von barcelona
nach düsseldorf das flugzeug hat heute
morgen um 6 uhr 48 düsseldorf verlassen
und ist mit 122 passagieren nach
barcelona geflogen und ist dort
pünktlich um acht uhr 57 gelandet das
flugzeug hat barcelona um 10 uhr 1
verlassen
mit dem ziel düsseldorf an bord waren
144 passagiere darunter zwei babys und
insgesamt sechs besatzungsmitglieder
2 im cockpit und vier in der kabine als
flugbegleiter das flugzeug hat so sind
unsere erkenntnisse jetzt um 10 uhr 35
es sollte um 11 35 landen und es hat um
10 uhr 45
seine reiseflughöhe von 38.000 fuß der
regulären reiseflughöhe auf dieser
strecke erreicht das flugzeug hat diese
reiseflughöhe nach einer minute wieder
verlassen und ist in einen sinkflug
eingetreten
dieser sinkflug so sind unsere
erkenntnisse jetzt zur stunde hat
insgesamt acht minuten gedauert
der kontakt des flugzeuges zu den zum
französischen radar und den
französischen fluglotsen ist um 10 uhr
53 auf einer höhe von zirka 6.000 fuß
abgebrochen
das flugzeug ist dann verunglückt das
flugzeug hatte die gerade erwähnt 144
germanwings gäste und sechs
besatzungsmitglieder an bord
bei dem flugzeug handelt es sich um
einen airbus a 320
mit der amtlichen kennung hpx
das flugzeug ist 1991 von airbus an
lufthansa ausgeliefert worden und ist
seitdem unterbrochen für lufthansa und
seit januar 2014 für germanwings
unterwegs gewesen
der letzte routinecheck des flugzeuges
hat gestern am 23 märz in düsseldorf
durch die lufthansa technik
stattgefunden
der letzte reguläre checks der letzte
große check des flugzeuges ist planmäßig
wie in den airbus handbüchern im sommer
2013 hat im sommer 2013 stattgefunden
beim kapitän des flugzeuges handelt es
sich um einen kapitän der seit über zehn
jahren für lufthansa und germanwings im
einsatz ist und auf dem modell airbus
bis heute etwas über 6000 flugstunden
geflogen ist
ein team der german wings ist zur stunde
in düsseldorf um den angehörigen
der auf der auf der flugpiste
befindlichen namen und der angehörigen
zu informieren
bitte haben sie verständnis dass wir
selbstverständlich zunächst sowohl
unsere gäste als auch die unsere
kollegen im cockpit und kabine und deren
angehörigen informieren bevor wir
namenslisten bekannt geben können
ein team von lufthansa airbus
germanwings und lufthansa technik ist
auf dem weg zur stunde auf dem weg zur
absturzstelle
um bei der untersuchung des unfalls das
bestmöglichste beizutragen um
schnellstmöglich herauszufinden warum
unser airbus verunglückt das wichtigste
zur stunde ist aber unser tiefstes
bedauern
gegenüber den gästen
den angehörigen der gäste den
angehörigen unserer groove über den
verlust ihrer angehörigen
unsere gedanken und gebete sind
ausschließlich mit unseren mit den
opfern
wir werden parallel selbstverständlich
zusammen mit den behörden alles tun um
die ursache dieses unfalls
schnellstmöglich und voll umfänglich
aufzuklären habe bei der auflistung der
die expertentipps die unterwegs sind
gerade natürlich ist dort das luftfahrt
bundesamt und die französischen behörden
selbstverständlich diejenigen die eine
untersuchung leiten und die wir
unterstützen nach besten wissen und
gewissen
vielen dank
würde sie jetzt bitten kurzem nahm und
die redaktion zu sagen sogar vergessen
nacheinander ab
zwei fällen gab es noch zu verstärken
die passiven vor dem hintergrund
meldungen zum 28
ich habe für alles was das fliegen die
fachexperten fragen des fliegens haben
wir unseren chef pilot kennt schreibt
hier nur eine information wie in diesen
fällen müssen wir jetzt sehr genau
schauen wo kommen welche informationen
her wir sind auch deshalb sehr daran
sehr wichtig für uns dass wir die
genauen ursachen so schnell wie möglich
auftaucht aufklären können
notruf können wir aktuell noch keine
genaue aussage treffen auch wir haben
dazu widersprüchliche aussagen bekommen
auch von der radar leitstelle
da sind wir aktuell noch in der klärung
ob da ein notruf abgesetzt wurde oder
nicht
zur zweiten frage mit dem sinkflug auch
da ist momentan nicht zu sagen warum der
kollege jetzt in den sinkflug gegangen
ist und das auch so schnell und ohne das
vorher mit der flugsicherung
abzusprechen
also auch da haben wir aktuell keine
weiteren hinweise zum weise fakten die
darauf schließen könnte
weshalb er den sinkflug gegangen ist
dankeschön
es gibt keinerlei auffälligkeiten an der
maschine selbstverständlich wird jetzt
der genaue die genau historie der
letzten tage und wochen dieses
flugzeuges exakt dokumentiert das ist
alles in den büchern vorhanden aber das
ist glaube ich ganz wichtig wir können
jetzt noch nicht spekulieren
es ist erst vor wenigen minuten
eigentlich passiert und wir können uns
im augenblick primär um die angehörigen
kümmern
was immer wir können um dort klarheit zu
haben und wir müssen dann mit allem was
wir in der luft unserer gruppe haben
schraubtechnik ob flugbetrieb ob cockpit
besatzungen und alle anderen experten
zusammen mit den behörden zusammen mit
airbus schnellstmöglich herauskriegen
was ist genau passiert
vor einigen tagen bekanntgeworden dass
bald die erste frage wir gehen heute zur
stunde davon aus dass 67 deutsche
staatsbürger an bord waren diese zahl
kann sich aber noch ändern da wir bei
buchungen beim check-in das nicht
unbedingt in jedem einzelfall prüfen
können
dies ist die passagierliste liegt vor
und sie wird in diesen minuten in
düsseldorf mit dem dort anwesenden
angehörigen natürlich vertraulich und in
privatsphäre ausgetauscht zur frage des
321 der kinder genau da kann ich also
sagen und zwar dieses problem was sie
ansprechen computerproblem nach der 320
ja wohl gehabt hat kann man aktuell bei
unserer fliegern sagen dass diese
computer ausgetauscht wurden
also die hatten jetzt die neueste
version von airbus verbaut so dass
dieser fehler dort eigentlich hätte
vorkommen dürfen
bitteschön der kollegen zuschnitt
wir werden alles tun was möglich tun
deshalb werde ich da auch jetzt keinen
zeithorizont leben sondern die werden
alles zusammen mit den behörden zusammen
mit dem hersteller zusammen mit allen
experten natürlich so schnell wie
möglich aber auch so
wir wollen wissen was passiert ist das
ist unser unsere verpflichtung gegenüber
den anderen richtung gegenüber den aber
auch gegenüber den angehörigen aller die
für germanwings arbeiten und aller
passagiere die täglich mit uns fliegen
das die airbus der airbus 320 gibt es
ungefähr seit diesen jahren und sie
werden seitdem unfallfrei in der
lufthansa gruppe eingesetzt
von daher gibt es verschiedene flugzeuge
innerhalb der gruppe die in diesem jahr
ging die fabrik verlassen haben ich
glaube dass wir einen der und das ist
traurig an einem tag wie heute das wir
stolz sind auf die qualität unserer
sicherheitsanstrengungen unserer
ausbildung sowohl im cockpit als auch in
der technik unsere gruppe fliegt seit 60
jahren nach diesen standards
selbstverständlich wird alles was durch
die aufklärung dieses unfalls nötig ist
was was die was zur klärung beitragen
kann von uns auch durchgeführt
wir setzen im flugbetrieb ganz normal
weiter fort
ich weiß es leider nicht weil sie bei
der buchung ihren namen ihre e mail
adresse oder ihre keine weiteren daten
die wenn sie durch die es gibt keine
passkontrolle in spanien weil das zum
schengen raum gehört auch das werden wir
schnellstmöglich jetzt aufklären
es ist die vermutung ich wollte noch mal
sagen es ist im augenblick der
wissensstand wir wissen genau wer an
bord war
wir wissen exakt wer wo im flugzeug
gesessen ist aber wir klären das jetzt
zunächst erstmal mit den angehören
berlin
preis von monaco im feld
msg systems
absolutely have three aus germany in
pace besten wenn ich auf deutsch
antworten darf das ist einfach zu viel
spekulieren gerade ja wir haben ein sehr
erfolgreiches flugzeug von dem es über
9000 exemplare auf der welt gibt das
einen fantastischen sicherheits record
hat eine historie und sicherheit genauso
wie die unsere produkte von boeing die
es in unserer gruppe gibt und wir müssen
das jetzt aufklären so schnell wie
möglich aber pop
bergers acht minuten
sehen sie mir es nachricht kann das
nicht beantworten weil es gibt viele
viele gründe warum das so gewesen sein
kann ob das bewusst gewesen ist
unbewusst gelesen es ist es alles wilde
spekulation und ich tue mir sehr sehr
schwer damit jetzt wirklich eine aussage
zu treffen was wirklich der grund ist
warum der kollege den sinkflug
eingeleitet hat also deswegen kann ich
ihnen diese frage so aktuell nicht
beantworten wir müssen tatsächlich
klären was die gründe sind dafür
brauchen wir die black boxes wir
brauchen informationen von unfallstelle
und dann müssen wir das gemeinsam mit
den behörden den französischen den
spanischen und aber besonders auch den
deutschen behörden klären und werden das
jetzt auch sehr zügig also wirklich
sofort angehen
das kann ich ihnen nicht sagen ich weiß
es nicht das ist ja genau die frage ich
glaube da müssen wir klären ob das
bewusst wahr oder unbewusst war wir
können tatsächlich nicht spekulieren wir
wissen das sind die daten die wir durch
die radar contact kontakt kennen zurzeit
wenige stunden nach dem unfall gibt es
keine weiteren daten die uns verfügung
stellen die kollegen ganz
von solchen haben damit auch schulen
ich kann es euch wir werden die
nationalitäten der opfer
sobald wir sie zweifelsfrei und in jedem
einzelheiten jedem für jeden einzelfall
können auch bekanntgeben
im augenblick kann ich ihnen die frage
nicht beantworten
diack
ich kann ihnen die genaue genaue zahl
nicht sagen ich weiß dass es mehrere
hundert sein werden die für die
lufthansa gruppe fliegen für die
germanwings sind es zur zeit etwas über
die für firmen links fliegen für die
gesamte lufthansa gruppe sind es mehrere
hundert
und in der seitdem dass das flugzeug
gibt sind mehrere tausend in betrieb
genommen worden
so wie sie es verstehen können
wir möchten zur zeit keine informationen
bevor nicht alle angehörigen informiert
sind
wir werden sie alle sobald das passiert
es auch bei nächster gelegenheit dazu
informieren kann ich tatsächlich was
sozusagen primär stützen wir uns
natürlich auf die daten die wir von
einer radarkontrolle aus frankreich
bekommen
alles andere ist nicht validiert und
wird auch denke ich nach einer
gründlichen überprüfung der wahl iden
radardaten aus frankreich somit nicht
für eine unfalluntersuchung herangezogen
werde jetzt die letzten fragen zu
leisten damit damit wir uns auch wieder
um den
da kann ich was zu sagen es ist aktuell
so dafür einen so genannten mission
slide organisieren werden wo wir
kollegen von uns kollegen aus der
lufthansa gruppe dorthin transportieren
werden mit einem flugzeug und dort
wahrscheinlich auf ein hubschrauber
zurückgreifen werden um an die
unfallstelle zu kommen also es ist
tatsächlich so dass diese unfallstelle
nur schwer zugänglich ist und deswegen
müssen wir dann jetzt auf solche
maßnahmen zurückgreifen
dort die letzte frage bitte
also wir haben irgendwie uhrzeiten
nochmal die uns jetzt vorliegen
departure war um 10 uhr 1 in barcelona
die reguläre flughöhe und 10 45 erreicht
worden
38.000 fuß und knapp 1000 liter 12.000
meter
die reguläre flug höhere wurde circa das
sind unsere informationen zur stunde
eine minute geflogen um sie um 10 uhr 45
wieder zu verlassen um zur frage der
kommunikation im cockpit der erscheint
also die aktuelle information ist die
wir bekommen haben das ist keine
kommunikation gab für den sinkflug das
heißt es wurde keine freigabe von den
radarlotsen den französischen
radarlotsen beantragt um die für cool zu
verlassen
die jetzige der stadtinformation jetzt
werden wir versuchen jetzt alles ich
würde sie bitten verständnis haben dass
wir es wieder den griechen stadt gehen
und uns um das flugzeug um die
angehörigen zu kümmern
wir werden sie informieren sobald
gesicherte informationen vorliegen jeder
das unter heute seien jetzt der für sie
wieder einladen hoffe innerhalb der
nächsten stunden